members are voting on a ban of  single-use plastic items such as straws  plates and cotton buds other plastics  like drinks bottles will be limited and  recycled at a rate of 90% by 2025  Parliament is voting on new standards  for drinking water across the EU  measures include cutting pollutants  improving distribution in public places  and promoting universal access to water  members continue their debate on EU  reform with European leaders this time  they exchanged views on the future of  Europe with Romania's president klaus  johannes european parliament president  Antonio Tajani announces the winner of  the 2018 Sakharov Prize for freedom of  thought finalists of the Ukrainian film  director oleg sentsov eleven NGOs saving  lives in the Mediterranean and the  Moroccan activist NASA is eff Safi  members are discussing ways to ensure  social media platforms comply with EU  data protection law to counter the  improper use of EU citizens personal  data by companies